all right so elon musk has taken the
tesla out to
yawned around the outer space and we're
taking the tesla out into the waters
yeah so it's tiff's birthday today and i
have decided to take
us out on a ferry ride as well as with
our car
this is coveted friendly that's why yes
it's covet friendly
fairy riding across balboa island from
balboa island to back to
newport beach i guess i don't know i
actually have no idea where we're going
we just got on this ferry
and oh we're moving we've been moving oh
yeah it was pretty slow
yeah now i feel that i feel the bumps
now that's pretty cool
happy birthday
how's your birthday been so far it's
been a really relaxing day today
yeah we're starting the vlog late very
late this is the this is the festivities
that we're doing tonight
yeah this is cool i mean it's been
really chill so far
just relaxing at home enjoying all the
birthday wishes from everyone and
birthday calls
and and then i got all dolled up because
i'm like i don't know what we're doing
because casey wouldn't tell me but
this is fun just being on the ferry like
my car is actually over water right now
i know i've never done this before in my
life so this is like a like a bucket
list thing that we get to check off
and it's a local thing you know how we
like never explore
our own homes like like the socal
stuff to do and this is a really cool
thing to do check that out get a shot of
that
it's so pretty all right we're pulling
into port
look this is what it looks like it's a
short ride this is what i look like
during the day
no because the lighting makes a
difference oh i actually did my eye
shadow and i don't think you could tell
in the night time
no but the reason why i'm saying it's
because that was on the way here but
but now it's night time it's actually my
fault because casey was trying to get
out here an hour before
we actually got here so it's my fault we
got here
this is kind of cool i like the i like
the the moodiness now yeah it's like
kind of got a little mood to it it's
romantic welcome to palboa island
seatbelts everybody got mine on
[Music]
oh lady you're about to get run over
lady oh that was fun
oh wait we need to put lights on that's
why oh snaps that was our fault
i turned them off i was like why does
everyone not know we're coming it's
because our car is also so
so quiet no true i forgot to turn off
the the lights back on
i mean to turn the lights back on that's
what i'm trying to say now we get to
walk around
and explore new park beach
like ever so let's find a place to park
is this like an
island i think they call it an island
but it's really not an island it's like
it's connected
it is it is an island oh it is an island
yeah an island
that's an island yeah let's walk around
[Music]
here
[Music]
yeah it's cute but this is actually like
real people hmm
who are they david and libby married 63
years old
it's gonna be me and you one day
[Music]
you know how people say people are more
attractive with masks on
do i look more attractive for the mascot
it looks
very attractive with or without hey i
like that answer
you look the same thing with or without
[Music]
you know that so like the whole
procedure to get there you have to park
at this random
parking lot it's like dark it's just
there's nothing here
in the middle of newport beach somewhere
and the shuttle is here to pick us up
and on our way to the restaurante
all right so i'm super excited about
this place because this restaurant's
placed
right on the beach so ideally we would
have booked a dinner that
would have the sun still up but sun sets
at like four
now so a little tour oh the beach is
really right here it's really really
close
i can see with my own eyes this is so
cool i can only imagine what it looks
like during the day
i know this is one of the really really
beautiful beaches
in socal too crystal cove is where they
have like clear water
oh really yeah next time we'll come back
with the sun
[Music]
cheers happy birthday baby thank you
all right so we're sharing a wedge salad
here got some white wine
and some skewers
[Music]
i'm kind of jealous of that i kind of
want that damn it looks so good are you
serious looking at your plate
that's pretty good too
what was that
[Music]
dude that's so pretty that's
[Music]
[Music]
i know this is my bottle look at how
heavy this
this man pours i have a heavy hand i'm
sorry i'm sorry you poured it like here
cheers to that curious or heavy pour
and he got a virgin pina colada
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's for anyone that doesn't want to
drink this in puerto rico we haven't had
a dining experience of this
magnitude in forever besides the corn
you know you well before the quarantine
like we just haven't gone out all that
time
it's like a year i feel like it's been
like a year since we've done something
like this
yes maybe more more maybe more but yeah
so we
chose to go all out she's got the uh
what is that
chilean seabag scallops with scallops
and mashed potatoes and asparagus
and i got the rib eye steak with the
lobster tail
with uh broccolini and mashed potatoes
and isaac this is like it's almost kind
of like your birthday too
like this is the first time you've ever
ordered like a 30 steak
huh 48 48 steak never mind
how's that 48 dollar steak taste so
amazing
yeah it's kind of like we're we're
celebrating christmas
together because we're not going to be
together for christmas mercy's gonna
stay
break on like like my second
thirtieth birthday because last year i
didn't get to celebrate with you guys
true
so i'm 30 years old not thirty-one
and then also it's just a
farewell 2020 how about that oh yeah
good riddance 2020.
cringy yeah we all got to save jumanji
jumanji why was that i don't know i
didn't know that what does that mean
let me stop playing this sport oh i get
it i get it i get it
jumanji wow it's yours in front but you
guys gotta share
yeah we'll we'll share it meeting you
isaac this one's all for mommy thank you
so much
happy birthday to
you candle happy
birthday to you
happy birthday
there we go did you make a wish i made a
wish uh
the other day oh okay
whipped cream uh ice cream brownie that
looks bomb
[Laughter]
oh yeah nice nice one of the reasons why
i picked this restaurant was because
they have beignets on the menu
and the yelp reviews all talk about
beignets and all that
arizona might have to put a rain check
on the beignets
oh no no we're
like okay i gotta catch up so now i'm
drunk it makes everything taste better
though when you're drunk
there's an event right here too oh
there's a heat vent right there
yeah well you got the best scene like
right now
yeah it's like the best scene in town
you got the heat vent down below and
then you get like
front row seats like we actually got the
closest seat to the ocean
right there's the
i can ocean see you but i can't i can
see you a little bit
it's a full moon tonight yeah i gotta
charge my crystals that nikki gave me
for my birthday yeah what she
she gave you like a really cool present
yeah she gave me this water bottle that
came with crystals and then i have to
charge the crystals
charge them with good energy and then
drink out of the water bottle with the
crystals inside
the thing you're saying makes any sense
like to like ingest the good energy
energy gotcha i get to be a
crazy crystal lady with her i like it
it's so
interesting you're so cute
what are you doing dancing dick dog
dance
dare you to jump in the to the water
right now how much
how much he does have a waterproof juice
oh he does
oh you can't go past your ankle 100
bucks
[Music]
thank you so much you're welcome you've
been reading so much
you've been doing audio books and
reading simultaneously i figured
[Applause]
kind of like i'm the only one with those
masks i know right yeah it was so funny
because me and isaac were trying to
figure out how to get it thing into your
car
i totally picked up on it really i'll
play it cool
oh dang it we're not we weren't smooth
enough how'd you pick up on it it was
really cute
how you're like i gotta use the bathroom
okay
i'm like he's probably up to something
but it was also
extra obvious because then casey was
like oh we're taking your car okay we're
taking
mommy's car yeah
because like the plan was to get the
thing into my car
i know yeah dang it okay also really
funny too because then when i
when isaac was like using the restroom i
was doing other things to finish up
like in the downstairs and then i went
to the car and then
i put all my stuff down and then i had
to go and put my shoes on
which is by the trunk so then once i go
to put my shoes on
he opened the door he was like oh i
forgot something
it was so cute but i was like how cute
they're trying to like hide something
for me
so then when i sat in the passenger seat
i was gonna keep doing my makeup
but i didn't want to put down the the
mirror because then i was gonna see
through the trunks yeah i was trying to
like keep it a surprise for myself too
so
i was just like doing other stuff well
i'm like okay they're done with the
trunk okay they're done with the trunk
you guys played it off so well though
thank you
[Music]
so we can just wait out this wine i'll
set up my kindle there we go and then go
home yay
thank you
[Music]
you